beautiful oh gosh I never thought such a
little trip like I'm looking at that's
gorgeous it ants and it's a beautiful
room I almost said your age because you
gave me permission but I realized that
was about to make you a year older
you're only 94 in part start wearing out
your legs start wearing out the one
thing that my children always say but
nothing happened to your mouth I got my
mouth cause the first time we were there
I brought a group of young women who
work with us at Ted and into the kitchen
and we were all standing around and
you'd already cook lunch for hundreds of
people as you do every day and you you
looked up at them you have to share with
this audience what you said to those
young women well you know I talk to
young women all the time and it's
beginning to bother me because look how
far I came you know I've come with women
that had to really hustle and work hard
and they knew how to be women they
didn't play that man down and we were
we'd in there the education you have
today and God I'm so proud when I see
those women with all that education
under their belt that's what I work hard
tried to get everybody to use those
resources so I took you know they just
don't know their power and I always tell
them just look at my mother had 12 girls
before she had a boy so you know how I
came up yeah she had 14 children she
reads 11 of us out of
at 14 and up until last year we were all
still living a bunch of old biddies but
we still here and sometimes we can be
just cantankerous and blah blah blah but
we still go but and I I'd love to see
women you don't know what it does for me
to see women in the position that you're
in today I never thought I'd see that I
never thought I'd see women be able to
take places in positions that we have
today it is just a powerful thing and a
young woman come to me she was
african-american woman and I said well
what do you do honey she said I am a
retired Navy pilot god that just melted
me because I knew how hard it was to
integrate that Navy
you know the Navy was the last thing to
really be integrated and that was done
by Franklin Roosevelt for it's a favor
to a african-american man Lester Granger
that I knew very well he was the
national head of the National Urban
League back there and when Roosevelt
asked him he wanted to appoint Lester as
maybe one of his cabinet members Lester
said no I don't want that all I want you
to do is integrate that Navy and that
was what Franklin did well Franklin
didn't live to do it but Truman did it
but when this woman told me I have flown
everything there is to fly Mama's death
all kinds of claims she was just I was
so it just melted with you you know to
see how far women have come and I told I
said well you could you could get him to
put the space program she said but miss
chase I'm too old
she was already 60 some years old and
you know you over hey old man
they don't weren't you flying up in the
sky at 60 Sun years those stay on the
ground but I and it just when I meet
women and today everybody comes to my
kitchen and you know that and it upsets
telling my daughter she doesn't make
people come in in the kitchen but that's
where I am and that's where you're gonna
see me in the kitchen so when they come
there I meet all kinds of people and
that is the thing that really uplifts me
is when I meet women on the move when I
meet women on the move it is good for me
now I'm not one of these flag-waving
women you're not gonna see me out there
way even no I don't do that no I don't
do that not I want any of you do that
just be good women and you know my
mother told us she was tough on us and
she said you know Leah she taught gave
us all this plaque to be a good woman
you have to first look like a girl well
I thought I'd look like a girl act like
a lady that I never learned to do think
like a man I don't act like that man
think like a man and worked like a dog
we learned that the hard way and they
talk to that they taught you what women
had to do we were taught that women
control the behavior of men how you act
they were like so you got to do that and
I tell you all the time you know don't
play this man down
it upsets me when you may have a husband
that maybe he doesn't have as much
education under his belt as you have
but still you can't play him down you
got to keep lifting him up because you
don't want to live with a mouse so you
want that man to be a man and do what he
has to do and anyway always remember he
runs on cheap gas so feeling
cheap gas and then you got it but it's
just so you have to give us a minute to
take that but I heard this young lady
speak before I came out she was so
beautiful the way she and I wished I
could be like that and my husband for
darling I lost him after we were married
70 years didn't agree on one thing
nothing but we got along together
because he learned to understand me and
that was just hard you know because he
was so different and that lady reminded
me I said if I was just being like her
Jackie but I really loved it but I was
and I was always pushy always moving
always doing this and he used to come to
me all the time you say honey God's
gonna punish you you you just not
grateful but it isn't that I'm not
grateful but I think as long as you live
and you gotta keep moving
gotta keep trying to you have to keep
going keep trying to do a little bit
every day every day you do a little bit
try to make it better and that's been my
whole life well I came up in the country
small town had to do everything had to
hold the water I have to watch the road
do this that picked a dumb strawberries
all that kind of stuff but still my
daddy insisted that we act nice we kind
and that's all when I heard this young
woman thought she sounds so beautiful
she just thought I wish I could be like
that this is church we don't want you to
be any different there was no question
about that
let me ask you when this is why it's so
wonderful to have a conversation with
someone who has such a long view too
long remembering rose
the person he did that favor for I mean
what is in your head and your mind and
what you have seen in witnessed one of
the things that it's good to remember
always is that when you open that
restaurant whites and blacks could not
eat together in this city it was against
the law my mom yet they did the Dookie
chase tell me about that well my
mother-in-law first started this and the
reason she started it because her
husband was sickly and he was he would
go out and people from Chicago and all
the places you would call his job a
numbers ramen but in New Orleans we are
very sophisticated so it wasn't a
numbers run it was a lot of endor so you
see we put class to that but that's how
he did and he couldn't go from house to
house but to get his clients and all
that so because he was think so she
opened up this little sandwich shop so
she was gonna take down the numbers
because he was sick a lot he was here
felt since he was really bad for a long
time but so she did that and not knowing
anything but she knew she could make a
family she knew she could cook and she
borrowed $600 from every
can you imagine start a business today
with $600 and no knowledge of what
you're doing and I always it just amazed
me of what she can do she was a good
money manager that I'm not my husband
used to call me a bankrupt sister she's
been everything you got and I would you
kept the restaurant open though if I
tempted even in those times of
controversy when people were protesting
and boy almost boycotting I mean it was
a controversial move that you it was
been made was and I don't know how we
did it but as I said my mother-in-law
was a kind kind person and you didn't
have
any african-americans on a police force
at that time they were all white but
they would come around and she would say
baby I'm a picture of Sandwich so she
would fix up a sandwich give him today
they would call that bribery but she was
just that kind of person she liked to do
things for you she liked to give so she
would do that maybe that helped us out
because nobody ever bothered us we had
Jim Dombrowski over Ben Smith who
started but all kinds of things right in
that restaurant and nobody ever bothered
us so we just did it
excuse me Fenner you talked to me that
day about the fact that people
considered the restaurant a safe haven
where they could come together
particularly if they were working on
civil rights Human Rights working to
change the laws we couldn't nobody once
you got inside those doors nobody ever
ever bothered you the police would never
come in and bother our customers never
so they felt safe to come there they
could eat they could plan all the
Freedom Riders that's where we planned
they planned all their meetings they
would come and we would serve a bowl of
gumbo and fried chickens so I said we
changed the course of America over a
bowl of gumbo and some fried chicken I
would like to invite the leaders not
just come here Bo and I'm going some
fried chicken company when we go out and
we do with the
[Applause]
we send you a less to invite - because
that's what we're not doing we're not
talking come together I don't care if
you Republican know what you're come
together talk and I know those old guys
I was friendly with old guys like Tip
O'Neill and all those people they knew
how to come together and talk and and
you would disagree maybe that's okay but
you were talking we come to a good thing
in meat and so that's what we did in
that restaurant we would plan that they
would plan the meeting arrest his mother
or at the Haley's mother she was big in
court my mother worked to me for 42
years
she was the and she was like me we
didn't understand the program nobody our
age understood this program but and we
sure sure didn't want our children go to
jail oh that was hole god but these
young people were willing to go to jail
for what they believe we were Kimba
Thurgood and all in ap2 row and all
those people with the NAACP but that was
a slow move we would still be out here
trying to get in the door waiting for
them but but I love Thurgood he was a
good move but they wanted to do this
without offending anybody I'll never
forget it Peter oh but you can't offend
the white people don't don't offend them
but these young people didn't care they
said we're going ready or not we're
gonna do this and so we had to support
them that these were the children we
knew virtuous children we had to help
they want to change and they brought to
change this is it was hard but sometimes
you do hard thing to make changes and
you've seen so many of those changes the
restaurant has been a bridge you have
been a bridge between the past and now
but you don't live in the past
you you know either very much in the
present and that's what you have to tell
young people today okay you can protest
you can do but put the past behind you I
can't make you responsible for what your
grandfather did that's your grandfather
I have to build on that I have to make
changes I can't stay there and say oh
well look what they did us then look
what they did now you remember that but
that makes you keep going on but you
don't hop on it every day you move and
you move to make a difference and
everybody should be involved my children
said mother don't get political you know
don't get political peace you know we
don't like that but you have to be
political today you have to be involved
be a part of the system look how it was
when we couldn't be a part of the system
when Dutch Morial became the mayor it
was a different dealing in their
african-american community we felt a
part of things now we got a mare we feel
like we belong moon tried before Dutch
came mayor Landrieu's follow mayor
Landrieu's father he took great great
risk by putting african-americans in
City Hall
he took a whippin for that for a long
time but he was a visionary and he did
those things that he knew was gonna help
the city you knew we had to get involved
so that's what we have to do we don't
hop on that we just keep moving and
Mitch you know I tell moon all the time
you did a good thing but Mitch did one
bigger than you and better when he
pulled those statutes are nothing more
you're crazy
[Applause]
but it was a good political move you
know when I saw PT bird guard come down
I was sitting I'm looking at the news
and it just hit me what this was all
about to me it wasn't about race it was
a political move and I got so pure it's
got back on that kitchen the next
morning I say come on pick up your pants
and let's go to work cuz you're gonna
get left behind and that's what you have
to do you have to move on people move on
what they do it was gonna bring
disability to the city so you got that
disability move on it uplift yourself do
what you have to do and and do it well
and that's all we do that's all I tried
to do but you just gave the formula for
resilience right you are clearly the
best example we could find anywhere of
resilience so there must be something
you say like emotional strength I like
people with emotional and physical
strength and maybe that's bad for me my
favorite all-time general was George
Patton and you know that wasn't too cool
but but as surprising as I got George
Patton hanging in my dining room because
I wanna remember he set goals for
himself and he was gonna set out to
reach those goals he never stopped you
and I always remember his words lead
follow or get out the way now I can't
leave I can't be a leader but I can
follow a good leader but I am NOT
getting up early
if you can't leave
leaders need followers so if I help you
up there I'm gonna ride on your
coattails and I can't count to go to
feed you good your help so and that's
what life is all about everybody can do
something but please get involved do
something the thing we have to do in in
this city and notes it is mamas have to
start these mamas today you know they
have to start understanding when you
bring this child in the world you have
to make a man out of it you have to make
a woman out of it and that takes some
doing it takes sacrifice maybe you won't
have long fingernails maybe you will
have the pretty hair but that child will
be on the move and that's what you have
to do we have to concentrate on
education and making these children
understand what it's all about and I
hate to tell the gentleman it's gonna
take a good woman to do that it's gonna
take parties to just do what you have to
do it be gone but we can hell the rest
and we will handle the rest if you're a
good woman you can do that you heard
that first here we can handle the rest
you know mrs. chase thank you so much
well thank you taking time out from the
work you do every day in this community
you don't know what this does to me when
I see all of these people and come
together people come to my kitchen from
all over the world I had people come
from London not twice that's happened to
me first a man came and I don't know why
he came to this we do every year we do
the chef's do something called chefs
charity well it so happened I'm the only
was the only woman there and the only
african-american there on that stage do
you need demonstration and I would not
leave
I thought another woman come up there
too I'm like Gordon oh if they're gonna
carry me up there do you bring another
woman up here so they have another one
out so I could step down but this man
was from London so after that I found
the man in my kitchen he came to my
kitchen and he said I want to ask you
one question okay I thought it was gonna
answer some food why does all these
white men hang around you he couldn't
understand that I said we work together
this is the way we live in this city I
may never go to your house you may never
come to my house but when it comes to
working like raising money for this
special school we come together that's
what we do and still here comes another
man a woman elegantly dressed about a
month ago in my kitchen she said I don't
understand what I see in your dining
room
oh so what do you think she saw whites
and blacks together that's what we do
we meet we talk and we walk together and
that's what we have to do you don't have
to be my best friend to work to better
your city to better your country we just
have to come together and work and
that's what we do in this city we're
weird bunch down here and nobody
understands us but we feed you well
[Applause]